hey guys today I'm gonna give you my
best dairy tip a lot of people have
lactose intolerance they have allergies
to milk however it may not be the
lactose that you're intolerant to or
even an allergy it could be something
completely different but let me first
cover the symptoms of usually what
happens when a lot of people consume
dairy they might get abdominal pain
bloating gas nausea diarrhea okay and
they instantly think I'll have an
allergy or they're lactose intolerant
but within the casein family there's two
types there's a 1 and a 2 now a 1 is one
of the most common types of casein
proteins that people are exposed to and
the problem is it increases inflammation
okay and there's even some interesting
links between feeding your children milk
too early of an a.1 version and then
developing diabetes type 1 and that's
very interesting because a one uniquely
attaches to the beta cell which is
involved in diabetes type 1 now whether
that's totally 100% true or not I would
recommend not exposing your child to the
a1 version of casein at a very early age
because their immune system is
developing and if it is one of the
triggers then you want to avoid it
alright guys so here's my best tip for
dairy consume the a2 version of casein
in the form of goat cheese or sheep
cheese but not cow's milk cheese unless
you find a cheese that is at a two
version all right guys that's your tip
for the day I wanted to keep this short
and to the point
thanks for watching
so you know my viewpoint on this topic I
want to know your viewpoint what do you
think about this video go ahead and
comment down below